نحن هنا في قاعده هذه القاعده الجويه
التركيه الشهيره هذه القاعده تحولت في
الايام التي تلت الزلزال الى خليه نحل
حقيقيه ترسل مساعدات الى هنا وليس فقط من
هذه المدن من كل دول العالم المساعدات
التي تاتي من كل دول العالم هي تصب في هذه
القاعده هنا ومن ثم يتم نقل هذه المواد
والمساعدات سواء عبر الشاحنات
وعبر ايضا المروحيات
الانواع الاخرى من الطائرات الى المناطق
التي لا يمكن للشاحنات الوصول اليها
المروحيات هي تطير في المناطق الجبليه
ربما توصل للمساعدات الى المناطق الجبليه
الوضع في قاعده
المسؤولين الذين تحدثنا اليهم هو وضع
استنفار اقصى طبعا المناطق الجبليه التي
يتم النقل لها المروحيه الواحده تنتقل بين
عده مناطق جبليه ليس شرطا ان تقف في مكان
واحد الزلزال اثر بشكل مباشر على مساحه
كبيره وبالتالي هناك حاجه لنقل كل هذه
المعدات الى
المناطق المنكوبه طبعا هذه القاعده هي
تنسق معظم الرحلات الجويه التي تنتقل او
تنقل المساعدات وهي جزء كما اخبرنا
المسؤولون هنا من جهود الجيش التركي
لاغاثه المنكوبين في المناطق المتضرره من
الزلزال